in this lesson we're going to talk about
the sohcahtoa this is oftentimes
referred to as right triangle trig or
right triangle trigonometry and
basically what it is it's the ratio of
the sides in a right triangle and you
can express those ratios as the sine
cosine and tangent ratios this acronym
helps us to memorize
the ratio so basically s stands for sine
c stands for cosine and t stands for
tangent
but it's always going to be the second
letter divided by the third that's the
ratio so the sign is the opposite side
over the hypotenuse the cosine is the
adjacent side over the hypotenuse and
the tangent is the opposite opposite
side over the adjacent side so let's
look at an example here so
just a little demonstration so here in
this triangle if we want to find the
sine of angle a we position ourselves
over here
at angle a
okay
and you want to kind of just basically
look at the opposite side over the
hypotenuse so the opposite side would be
across that's seven
the hypotenuse is across from the right
angle that's 25 so the sine of a is
seven twenty-fifths
now the cosine of angle a you're
standing here again cosine is adjacent
adjacent means next to but you don't
want the hypotenuse you just want the
other side that's next to this angle so
adjacent over hypotenuse that's 24 over
25
and if you want the tangent of angle a
tangent's opposite over adjacent that's
7 over 24. now if you wanted to find the
measure of angle a like how many degrees
this angle is how how open that angle is
what you're going to want to do then is
use the inverse trig functions the
inverse sine inverse cosine inverse
tangent those are the ones that you see
above the sine cosine and tangent on
your calculator you'll have to probably
use your second key but basically here
if we wanted to find out what the
measure of angle a what we could do is
we could say well that's the sine
inverse okay of 7 25
or we could say that's the cosine
inverse
of 24 over 25 or the tangent inverse of
7 24. so whenever you want to solve for
the missing angle you're going to use
the inverse trig function if you know
the angle like in this problem here
you're just going to use a regular sine
cosine or tangent so like if we wanted
to find this side
we position ourselves at this angle over
here okay and we say the adjacent side
and the hypotenuse let's see adjacent
and hypotenuse that's cosine so what we
have is we have the cosine of 15 degrees
equals the adjacent side which is 100
over the hypotenuse which is x now what
we can do is we can just cross multiply
okay across the equal sign so that's x
times the cosine of 15
equals 100 times one and then divide
both sides by cosine of 15
and then you can do that on your
calculator and get the value of that
missing side so let's do a couple
examples see if you can pause the video
and just do them on your own and we'll
go through them together
example one says for an angle beta
in a right triangle cosine of beta is 8
17 and tangent of beta is 15
what is the value of sine of beta
okay so what i recommend on these types
of problems is to just draw a right
triangle like so here's beta
you can just think of it as angle b and
basically the cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse and the tangent
is opposite
over adjacent so now we have all three
sides of the triangle here we want to
find the sine of beta sine is opposite
over hypotenuse so that's going to be 15
17.
another way to do this problem is if you
want to memorize the tangent
is equal to the sine over the cosine
so in this case if you know the tangent
you put that here and if you know the
cosine you can put that there and you
can solve the equation for the sine
either way you'll get the same result
okay for example two it says what is the
angle of elevation to the top of the
building so elevation is like from the
horizontal
you're elevating or you're looking up
right depression is like you're
depressed you're like looking down from
the horizontal okay
but
say there was somebody at the top of
this building like this looking down
over here at you
that would be the angle of depression
looking up that's the angle of elevation
but these angles are actually congruent
because they're alternate interior
angles because these lines are parallel
same thing with this here this height
would be the same as the height of the
building okay but to solve this problem
we want to find out what this angle is
and we need to look at the ratio of the
sides that we have we have 100 which is
the opposite side
and we have 180 which is the adjacent
side so opposite and adjacent that's the
tangent so let's go ahead and write an
equation here the tangent of theta
equals opposite over adjacent but to
solve for theta here
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the tangent inverse of both sides
you can see those are inverses and you
get the angle by itself so whenever
you're solving for that missing angle
you want to do the
inverse okay so tangent inverse of 100
over 180 you might want to check your
mode too make sure you're in degrees i
was in radians right now so just make
sure you're in the right
degrees or radians depending on the
problem so let's go ahead and do tangent
inverse of 100 divided by 180
and you can see it's coming out to about
29 degrees so that would be your
elevation right here
angle of elevation 29 degrees so the
sohcahtoa the sine cosine tangent ratios
definitely something important you want
to know and memorize for the ect